oh this is ruined
as you can see in the kitchen
wrecked once again by water this is the
third time Kim's home in Britain has
been devastated by floods and this is
your this is your life this is your
belongings yep yeah again
how are you feeling
this is a community on edge a day spent
watching the torrents worried this River
May burst its banks behind that was a
river and there's um about five foot of
river behind that wall so I I don't want
to under here too much longer so yeah it
is a dangerous situation and if that was
to go in any way anywhere
um I think that's what the whole lot
would probably get washed away
fear for Alice who's one of 300
residents scrambling to evacuate 52
years and I've never had to do it before
and how are you feeling about that I'm
just anxious
just I'm living on my own so if you do
get a bet on [ __ ] so I'm better with
family this northeast corner of Scotland
has once again borne the brunt of these
danger to life weather warnings there's
a sense of deja vu elsewhere across the
country there's been significant
disruption record rainfall has made the
roads treacherous made the railway lines
impassable and forced the closure of
schools and now an emergency Hall is
home to those who are now homeless in a
community feeling vulnerable once again
Conor Gillis Sky news briefing